[Music]
losing a limb
is nothing short of devastating but
modern technology has made it possible
to continue leading a normal life
the most common way to address the loss
is a prosthetic arm or leg which does a
pretty good job of returning some
flexibility and dexterity to the person
wearing it
earlier fake limbs couldn't do much but
as our tech evolved
so did prosthetics it's a great time to
be involved in prosthetic development
too
because there have been quantum leaps in
research and understanding of how the
human body works
some of the prosthetics we'll look at
today will amaze you
because of their ability to make you
part man
part machine but before we dive in
welcome back to our channel
if you haven't already make sure you hit
that subscribe button and ring the bell
so you never miss an upload from us
number 10.
ilim no it's not another product from
apple
the ilim is the world's first
commercially available bionic hand
released in 2007. there are several
versions of the hand
including the ilim access ilim quantum
and
eye limb titanium among others but the
basic foundation of the device is the
same across
all products these are
multi-articulating prosthetic hands with
five
individually powered digits offering an
electrically rotating thumb
with a manual override the way the hand
works is it allows you to have control
by using muscle twitches
in the stump area certain muscle
twitches trigger specific positions for
pre-configured grips
so for example two quick muscle twitches
will activate a pinch grip
and you can also control gestures and
set command shortcuts on the app
it also comes with auto grasp an
anti-drop safety feature
since its release the prosthesis has
only gotten more advanced
offering a speed boost feature that can
be increased to 30 percent
number nine power knee for people who
had to undergo above knee amputations
using traditional prosthetics can be
difficult you'd be adapting to a whole
different way of walking without
assistance from the knee but
ulcer came in with a solution a bionic
knee called the power knee
power knee helps active flexion and
extension while walking and facilitates
symmetrical weight distribution
so you have a more natural gait active
users have reported that the device
restored their endurance and reduced the
typical rehabilitation
time required after surgery the software
also enables prosthetists and physical
therapists to give users visual feedback
during training it logs and reports on
user performance and prosthetic use for
better reimbursement documentation
with the power knee users can walk
normally and more naturally
because it essentially replicates the
muscle activity needed to bend the legs
it can also learn the user's walking
pattern and gait to be more efficient
and comfortable
number 8. luke luke or
life under kinetic evolution is an arm
that has been under development for 10
years
it has been tested by 100 amputees and
used for over 10
000 hours it allows people to perform
more complex tasks than they can with
current prosthesis
in a way that better resembles the
natural motion of the arm
and it comes in different configurations
the arm is also strong enough to lift a
bag of groceries from floor to a
tabletop and even gives users a sense of
how firm they're grasping something
thanks to the built-in sensors but the
most impressive feature
is probably its ability to reach all the
way back and scratch your back when you
need it
it's all controlled from input devices
like emg
electrodes and pressure switches but
it's also possible to operate via
wireless imus that you wear in your
shoes
you and the clinical team will work
together to develop an input
configuration that best
meets your needs number seven finger
prosthesis
custom designed and suited to fit your
daily needs
naked prosthetics has durable finger
prosthetics to help people with finger
amputation
they are made from medical grade nylon
12 and have silicon rubber tip pads to
mimic natural fingertips
these improve grip strength and
articulation while also protecting you
from further injuries
these prosthetics are partly printed by
3d printers and partly made by machines
and there are three versions of them
depending on your needs the pip driver
is a body driven prosthesis designed for
people with amputations through the
middle phalanx
which is the first knuckle on your
finger each device is custom designed
within millimeters of the patient's
anatomy so mimicking their complex
motions is possible
the mcp driver model is designed for
people with amputations on the proximal
phalanx which is the base of your finger
the third type is the thumb arguably the
most important part of the hand
the thumb driver model features an
anchor design that tracks the patient's
natural motion
and provides a rigid structure to react
to the heavy forces generated by
opposition
the tip has an adjustable preflex and
the fingers are designed to work
uniquely with the thumb in opposition
number 6.
argus argus is a retinal implant created
by second sight that
improves vision in people affected by
retinitis pigmentosia
it works with a retinal implant and an
external camera mounted to eyeglasses
connected to a processor
the camera records the image processes
it then sends the information wirelessly
to the implants in the eye
the implant then stimulates the
remaining retinal cells to give the user
visual
information it's still only a limited
amount and it certainly doesn't cure
blindness
still it's definitely one step closer to
restoring vision for the blind
the surgery only takes a few hours and
is performed by second sight technicians
once it's in
the implant sits in around the back of
your eye it comes with all the
accessories
glasses a built-in camera and a portable
processing unit
after four weeks of having it implanted
you return to the clinic so that
technicians can activate argus for you
and program it for your specific needs
number 5.
um conversations are a huge part of our
lives
but certain advanced throat cancers
require the removal of the entire voice
box
sometimes you can still regain the
ability by implanting surgical devices
but these implants don't come cheap they
can sometimes even run up a cost of one
thousand dollars
but surgical oncologist dr vashal rao
developed a fully functional voice
prosthetic
specifically for throat cancer patients
and get this
it cost less than a dollar the oom
prosthetic managed to get
so cheap thanks to the manufacturers
suppliers and scientists who volunteered
their
time to the project the finished
prosthetic only costs about 75 cents
it weighs only a gram and is made from
medical-grade platinum-cured silicone
in addition to its ground-breaking
affordability um only takes about 15
minutes to surgically implant
it works thanks to a basic physics
principle that sound is created when an
obstruction is introduced to the passing
of air
air is redirected from the lungs to the
esophagus where food
normally passes this obstruction can be
used to create sounds that resemble
regular speech
the voice won't be as crisp and clear as
before surgery
but um still makes communication
possible for cancer patients who
otherwise would never have been able to
afford prosthetics
and by the way there are no electronic
parts to this prosthetic either
number four thought-controlled
prosthetics a robotic arm doesn't quite
provide the flexibility and dexterity
that a real arm does
obviously well the aim of modular
prosthetic limb
is to have the same functionality as a
normal arm all being controlled using
the mind
it's a bionic arm with human level
dexterity weight
range of motion and force generation as
the name implies
the arm is meant to be modular with it
being able to replace an
injured limb at any level testers for
the limb have noted that they have
gained the ability to differentiate
between their fingers
and sense the hardness of an object it's
a project developed by the john hopkins
university applied physics laboratory
funded under the revolutionizing
prosthesis number three
propio feet your feet do more for you
than you realize
they help you navigate uneven terrain
the way a robotic or prosthetic foot
couldn't
well that is until now the propriofoot
is a bionic foot for helping the user
navigate
uneven terrain it's an adaptive
microprocessor controlled ankle
the motor powered ankle motion increases
toe clearance in swing phase by raising
the forefoot
and reducing the risk of trips and falls
it also adjusts the ankle angle to
changing terrain
providing stable foot placement on
stairs and inclined surfaces
it helps reduce the compensatory
movements that users would usually make
with traditional prosthetics
from the lightweight material the
powered ankle and intelligent terrain
adaptation
the foot will soon allow users to walk
and stand naturally
number 2 bionic arm with a sense of
touch we sometimes take the sense of
touch for granted the defense advanced
research projects agency or
darpa for short has done a lot of
research on prosthetics
some of the company's most recent work
has focused on making the wearables feel
more natural
literally the developers were able to
mimic the sense of touch in a paralyzed
man
by placing a series of electrode arrays
onto both the sensory cortex and the
motor cortex
it wasn't perfect but the subject said
it almost felt like somebody was
touching his hand
when the researcher placed his hand on
the prosthetic and he could even tell
which finger was being touched
just through the sensations and now for
something a little more fun
number one the prosthetic tattoo machine
a tattoo artist's entire living is their
talent which they need hands for
of course if you have a lot of tattoos
you might appreciate french artist jc
chatontinet's prosthetic arm developed
with the assistance of fellow french
artist
j.l gonzal his arm is made of pieces
from a typewriter
manometer a traditional tattoo gun and
various pipes
along with the necessary sensors to
detect movement
pretty neat right with the help of this
device tenet has the full range of
motion he needs to tattoo intricate
designs on his clients
and that's it for this video which one
do you find most impressive
the 75 cent voice box is pretty cool let
us know your favorite ones in the
comments below
if you enjoyed this video make sure you
give it a like and check out more on the
simply tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time